- This never wavering, never
deviating from the strategy,
it's tiring.
It's exhausting.
It's also, unfortunately
for all of us,
the cost of entry
to be successful.
(light music)
- That's just
what has to happen.
Have to figure that out.
That's not up debate.
And I'm not sold that, I don't
know if that makes me a good guy
or a bad guy it's just my
natural state to slightly
over-deliver as close to the
middle as possible
and I like that.
- [AJ] When do they pay?
You both have four to
five years advance, right?
So they both have
four years to go.
You guys have been
on the rise again.
Yeah.
- Eric's here?
Congratulations married man.
- I appreciate it.
- Did you enjoy it?
- A fucking projector came out
of the roof, I turn around and
it's just you.
- Hey Niall, it's me
Gary Vaynerchuk, your CEO.
Cam, love you so much
congratulations.
What an amazing, amazing day.
Just want to make a quick video
and tell you guys
how much I love you.
How much I am so sad that I'm
not there and most of all how
proud I am that there are so
many Vanyer-ites, Vayner-ites?
I've never used
that term before.
VaynerMedia peeps at
the at the wedding.
Where's your ring?
(laughter)
Alright.
- (inaudible) Hoffler,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- How are you?
- Amanda Hoffler.
- Perfect.
Hey Amanda, how are you?
- Good.
- I've been a fan
since Crush It!
- Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
Were you able to use
any of Crush It! for you?
- Oh, yeah, totally
grew my business.
- So, literally on
an authentic level
the business was a certain
place, you read the book,
you did certain things,
good things happened.
- Applied everything you
talked about and yeah.
Even down to the
#AskGaryVee show.
- Yep.
- Right?
- Great, that's what I want.
That's what I want.
- My pleasure.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- [Amanda] Gary,
I have something for you.
- Yes? Well, thank you.
What is this?
(crosstalk)
Oh, man, I'm pumped.
So what is this?
- [Amanda] You'll
just have to open it.
- Okay.
- [Amanda] Self explanatory
once you open it.
- Once I get it?
- It's a cape, you can
fly around the stadium.
(laughter)
- By the way,
not only do I get it,
I think I might just
wear it all day.
(laughter)
I'm Super Jets Fan.
Good news, is the only
thing I put on camera.
The level of disrespect that
I have for them they know.
All of them.
I just don't respect them.
I think they're commoditized.
I love them.
By the way, a lot of them might
make more money but none of them
will have bigger impact.
- (inaudible)
- [Gary] Correct.
- [Tyler] We got to go.
- My friend.
- Great meeting you.
- Continued success.
We'll be in touch.
- [Kaspar] Stay in touch.
- I will.
- [Kaspar] I will too.
- [Gary] I'll be in touch. Yeah.
Where we going?
- [Tyler] You're going
to speak at PureWow.
- [Gary] Okay.
- What's up?
- [Gary] What's up, bro?
How are you?
- Got the tan going on.
- [Gary] We both have
longer beards than normal.
- I know.
(applause)
- Everybody has a voice now.
And that voice can travel and
everybody's opinion has way more
weight than it did a decade ago
and so when you play that out
what I've noticed is
something pretty scary.
Which is over
the last five years,
forget about even the election,
the enormous minority of
unhappy people in our society
are dramatically louder and are
impacting us more than the far
majority of us that are
happy and good and that's it.
And I think, I almost feel this
weird sense of responsibility
for somebody who can tweet and
have lots of people show up,
to have that many people paying
attention to what
I'm talking about.
There's only so much I can
do about being happy and
documenting my happy journey.
I'm trying to pressure the other
people that are
happy to talk about it too.
I just think we're in
a very awkward time.
I think it's rubbernecking and
it's just the way it is, right?
When we pay more attention to
the negative than the positive.
It's just how
I feel about the world.
I think human beings are the
most underrated
thing of all time.
When I think about our
capabilities to eliminate each
other, I'm being serious.
I know it's kind of a weird
place to go but like the fact
that we're still here, we're
hardwired in a way that allows
us to protect each other in a
net game yet the mainstream
media and the way we hear,
all you hear is negativity.
All that mainstream media
does is tell us about the
.0001% worst of us.
I think we as humans are going
to have some level sense of
responsibility that if you're in
a good place it might be good to
Tweet or Instagram or
Snapchat about that.
The volume of negativity is
just way too high in reality of
what's going on and I think the
silent majority of us and this
is what happens every empire
falls when the silent majority
of happy isn't loud enough and
they lose the branding game.
- Gary Vaynerchuk everybody.
(applause)
- Thank you.
Thanks guys.
The other variable is
I don't think we can,
hey man, how are you?
I don't think the other, I don't
think it's as easy as that.
By the way, I would tell you one
of the reasons we probably went
cold turkey was because
I became not interested in
having that conversation.
You know, if I really
think about it.
You know what I mean?
At some level we just should
really follow my blueprint
because I'm good
at it, you know?
Just one of the things we really
want to do with DailyVee is
create a little bit more color
commentary on top of some of the
things that you guys are seeing.
How do I layer more
context around some of
the conversations
you're picking up?
I think one thing that you've
seen over the last couple of
episodes is I've been
talking to Brandon a lot more.
During vacation,
Brandon is my best friend
and so it's fun to talk to
him when I have downtime
leads into Wine Library talk.
I've been very, very, very MIA
in the Wine Library environment
in 2016 when 2015 was the first
year I was kind of back into it
after three years and we
had a very successful year.
I created a different
strategy and framework.
We made a lot more money and it
kinda reminded my dad, Brandon
and definitely even myself
that hey maybe I'm good
at this business thing.
It's been interesting to watch
us deviate a little bit from my
structure in the first eight
months of this year and
we felt the effects.
We've not done as well.
I think one thing that I'm
fascinated by is even thought
Brandon is somebody I've known
since I was 14, even though
Brandon is somebody that
I worked with every day,
what the feedback
he's been giving me,
even though you
have a religion
you still have to go and pray.
Whether that's on
Saturday, Sunday, Friday.
You still have to
remind yourself.
You can't just say,
"I'm religious" and
then just live it.
It's like working out.
It's forever.
Great, you had two good years
of working out and being well.
If you let it go, you're gonna
go right back to where you are.
And so, this continuity,
this consistency,
this never wavering,
never deviating from
the strategy, it's tiring.
It's exhausting.
It's also,
unfortunately for all of us,
the cost of entry
to be successful.
The second you stop, you
could've won two Olympic golds
but if you didn't try as hard
because you weren't as hungry,
somebody else is, you show
up and you come in eighth.
It's just the way it is and so
it's been a lot of fun trying to
remind Brandon on key themes
which is most
things don't matter.
Trust your people.
Go fast.
As much you think you're doing,
you need to do a lot more and
watching the results at
Wine Library over the last three
weeks has been
rewarding and intoxicating.
I love the action of
retail and it's fun.
When you have multiple things
going on, a lot of those themes
have been motivating me in
the trenches at VaynerMedia and
making me look at
myself on myself.
I'm analyzing myself as if
I was analyzing Brandon and
I'm tweaking things
here and there and so
it's been really fun to
get back on the field
after couple weeks of vacation.
Very refreshed, very focused
and very much zeroed in on the
things that matter as we
go into the fourth quarter.
Good, alright.
- [DRock] Cool.
- [Gary] Good?
- [DRock] Yeah.
I don't have to come with you.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
(light music)